dis moi un peu si tu me racontait
comment tu t'es retrouvé avec toutes ses
médailles
oui alors c'est l'âge lui parce que j'ai
fait naître un bébé d'une main pendant
que je faisais un bras de fer avec un
look de salut c'est parce que j'ai
sauver des orphelins d'un incendie je
suis retourné chercher les berceaux et
ensuite les jouer et j'ai aussi
sauvegarder mes chiens qui avaient une
épine dans la pâte à sel là c'est pour
être course et d'avoir toutes les autres
voilà on est arrivés merci beaucoup pour
cet exposé instructif sur comment
dirais-je sur toi j'ai un cadeau pour
toi
marianne ça c'est gentillet waouh je
suis sans bois oui je sais ça fait
c'était fait larmes jeudi soir au dîner
trop fort